hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast multiplex
amino SA detection of Alzheimer's
disease biomarkers in several pot spinal
fluid plasma and serum presented by
Anthony pepper Rita a senior scientist
at Miller Poor's Sigma I'm Suzy Valdez
of lab Ruth and I'll be your moderator
for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by milla poor stigma
for information about our sponsor visit
WWE MD Miller poor calm before we begin
I want to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen and type those questions
into the drop down box that appear on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the help desk
button located in the promotional board
at the bottom center of your screen or
use that ask a question box to let us
know you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and best
offers continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process to obtain those
credits please join me now in welcoming
our presenter today Anthony sab Arita I
will now turn the presentation over to
him welcome sir hello thanks for the
introduction and thanks for tuning in to
this webinar my name is Anthony Supriya
and I'm a research & development
scientist within the immunoassay
platform solutions group at millibar
Sigma today I will be discussing some of
the immunoassay kits we are developing
to facilitate and further research on
neurodegenerative disease during this
webinar I will be covering a few topics
related to the immunoassay portfolio of
millibar Sigma first I will provide some
background on multiplex protein
detection technology then I will talk
about some of the assays we have
developed for neuroscience research
specifically highlighting a new kit
human neuroscience panel - that will
launch at the end of the month I will
share some data using this kit to
measure existing and emerging biomarkers
of Alzheimer's disease in cerebrospinal
fluid plasma and serum lastly I will
discuss one of our newest technologies
SMC which stands for single molecule
counting SMC is a high sensitivity
immunoassay that allows for protein
measurements at spencer gram per
milliliter concentrations we've recently
launched a new instrument the SMC X Pro
so I will provide some insight into this
new platform and share some data with a
new kit we've developed for it for the
measurement of the critical Alzheimer's
disease biomarker amyloid beta 42 for
well over a decade mullah por Sigma has
been developing assays using the multi
analyte profiling technology from
luminex for multiplex protein detection
conceptually the multiplex technology
that we use is similar to a traditional
Eliza with the caveat that the assay the
multiplex assay is taking place in
suspension and one of the features is
that you're able to conduct several
assays simultaneously within the same
sample this is made possible by the X
map technology from lumen X which
essentially provides a color-coded set
of magnetic microspheres that can each
be coated with a capture antibody and
distinguished by the Luminex
instrumentation when incubated with
sample and detection antibody sandwich
complexes formed consisting of the
capture bead the analyte of interest and
the detection antibody the addition of
streptavidin psychotron or SI PE for
short that's a reagent that's going to
bind to the biotin later detection
antibody and tag it with the
fluorescence reporter so then proteins
can be measured in multiplex fashion by
two lasers one of which will identify
the bead and thereby the analyte that
you're measuring
the other that will measure the
fluorescent signal associated with that
analyte
we have a few different instruments
capable of reading a Luminex based
multiplex SI picture here on the top is
the lumen X 200 we also have a flex map
3d instrument both of those instruments
use a flow cytometry based analysis
system and pictured below is the mag
picks which uses CCD imaging our milling
Plex assays can be run on both types of
instruments and although the fluidics
and optical components may differ the
assay principle remains the same
what are the advantages of running a
multiplex a safe versus a traditional
Eliza the major appeal of the multiplex
assay is the ability to measure several
proteins simultaneously from a single
sample so instead of purchasing and
running several Eliza's using up sample
with each experiment multiplexing helps
conserve samples thereby saving time and
money and another advantage to point out
is the wide dynamic range for Luminex
based multiplex assays the figure below
shows a comparison of the dynamic range
of an Eliza kit for the protein g f AP
versus a bead based luminix sa 4gf ap
which is from the catch human
neuroscience panel one when the Eliza
standard curve is evaluated alongside
the standard curve from the luminix
assay you can see that the multiplex GF
APSA covers a much wider range with
sensitivity that extends below one
nanogram per mil so when you're using
these kits to measure GF ap and CSF it I
and the CSF samples are represented by
those yellow diamonds it's apparent that
the multiplex assay can detect GF ap and
the CSF samples seven out of seven
samples whereas the Eliza the range
doesn't extend down far enough normally
getting detection and three out of the
seven CSF samples that were tested so
this is just one example but in general
the range and sensitivity of our Miller
Plex assays equals or exceeds that of an
Eliza
identifying biomarkers to include in our
kits is just the beginning
we have rigorous validation guidelines
to help ensure that our kits deliver
reliable performance below is a list of
the criteria that we use during kit
validation with most of our product
categories we typically validate with
serum and plasma however most of our
neuroscience panels are also validated
for cerebrospinal fluid or CSF during
validation we establish kit sensitivity
and confirm that there is no cross
reactivity between analytes in the panel
we do this by ensuring that a capture
bead directed against one protein does
not bind to the protein standard of
another analyte we also test precision
to ensure that to ensure that there's
reproducibility within the assay the
accuracy benchmark refers to spike
recovery assays where known quantities
of an analyte are spiked into the
samples and then the experimentally
determined values are compared to the
expected values linearity testing
determines whether the samples behave as
expected over a successive two Lucian's
for performance during spike recovery or
dilution linearity testing can indicate
potential matrix effects or other
factors interfering with the fidelity of
the assay we test where the samples are
going to fall on a standard curve as
well as how samples are going to be
affected by storage conditions we can do
that by heat stress and we also heat
stress the kit to approximate different
conditions that the kit could be exposed
to during the shipping process and if
there happens to be similar products on
the market we will compare we will
compare the multiplex kit performance
with the other assays such as Eliza's
now that I have provided some background
on the technology behind multiplex I
will discuss our kit portfolio as it
applies to neuroscience research we have
four human neurodegenerative disease
panels listed across the top and these
have been used extensively to study
Alzheimer's disease we also have
neuropeptide panels per human mouse and
rat the neuropeptide panels use a
competitive assay format to measure six
different neuro peptides these
neurodegenerative disease and
neuropeptide panels have been in the
middle former Sigma kit portfolio for
several years and have been featured in
numerous publications some of our newer
kits include the human amyloid beta and
tau panel and the mouse amyloid beta
panel and I'll speak more about the
amyloid beta peptide z' and the tau
protein and a few slides
each multiplex kit is packaged with all
of the components pictured here
including capture beads lyophilized
quality controls and a laugh alized
protein standard that is rehydrated and
thoroughly diluted by the end-user to
generate the standard curve and also
gets also come with a detection antibody
cocktail and si PE solution which is
your reporter wash buffer sa buffer a
96-well plate and plate sealers along
with the kit protocol additionally some
assays will include a serum matrix and
or a bead diluents
next I want to show you some data from
two of the products in our neuroscience
portfolio that we have recently
developed we use these kits to determine
the sample range of human CSF from
healthy donors and patients with
neurodegenerative disease so on the left
you see the standard curves for the
human amyloid beta and tau panel that
recognizes four targets that are amongst
the most well characterized biomarkers
of Alzheimer's disease the amyloid beta
40 and amyloid beta 42 peptides total
tau and tau phosphorylated at 3 and 181
the bottom-left figure provides an
example of data generated from this kit
showing an increase in phosphorylated
town in the CSF of Alzheimer's disease
patients relative to healthy controls
consistent with what's been established
and published reports on the top right
are the standard curves for analytes in
human neuroscience panel 1 so this kit
isn't so much focused on Alzheimer's
disease and instead contains analytes
relevant to a few other neurological
conditions for example human
Neuroscience panel one can detect
traumatic brain injury biomarkers such
as gf AP and uch l1 and Parkinson's
disease biomarkers like opposite
nucleons and bj1
one of the analytes in this panel NSE
has been used as a biomarker for a
variety of conditions and the figure on
the bottom right we are evaluating its
concentration and CSF samples from
patients with Alzheimer's disease
Parkinson's disease or healthy controls
and we do not observe significant
differences in NSE levels between these
conditions however we were able to
quantitate this biomarker over a broad
sample range in each patient cohort
you
you
a great resource for Alzheimer's disease
researchers is the all's form website
which includes a meta analysis of
Alzheimer's disease biomarkers and I'll
be referring to Alzheimer's disease
using a D throughout this presentation
this meta-analysis includes many of the
proteins currently in our neuroscience
product portfolio as well as some
emerging targets that we were interested
in developing assays for the size of the
bubbles in this figure corresponds to
the number of published studies that
were integrated into the analysis as you
progress up or down the y-axis from the
origin you observe more pronounced
differences in protein concentration
between normal CSF and Alzheimer's
disease CSF as you move further along
the x axis the observed differences take
on greater statistical significance the
three most well characterized
Alzheimer's disease biomarkers are a
beta 42 total tau and phosphorylated tau
these proteins are also critical to
Alzheimer's disease pathology as the
amyloid plaques and neurofibrillary
tangles that are hallmarks of
Alzheimer's disease are composed of the
amyloid beta and tau proteins
respectively some of the other proteins
in the meta-analysis that are already
present in our a portfolio include y
kale 40 which is an analyte in human
neurological disorders panel 3 and NSE
which is in human neuroscience panel 1
this analysis also contains several
proteins that we were interested in
adding to our assay portfolio as part of
human neuroscience panel 2 including two
of the exciting Alzheimer's disease
related proteins trem 2 and neuro
granite
trem - is a cell surface receptor
expressed on myeloid cells such as as
microglia trem - can be cleaved
resulting in a soluble fragment that
could be detected in cerebrospinal fluid
serum and plasma with increased amounts
of creme - observed in Alzheimer's
disease CSF neuro granite is a
postsynaptic protein whose levels are
also increased in Alzheimer's disease
CSF and may be a biomarker for synaptic
damage
show the standard curves and the analyte
list for human Neuroscience panel 2 in
addition to trem 2 and neuro Grandon
human neuroscience panel 2 contains
other analytes linked to
neurodegenerative disease one analyte
prion protein is predominantly known for
its role in prion diseases in which the
cellular isoform is converted to a Miss
folded pathogenic isoform this miss
folding propagates through the nervous
system accumulating and causing
neurodegenerative disease the cellular
prion protein is a surface receptor that
can interact with amyloid beta oligomers
and this interaction can regulate
intracellular signaling additionally CSF
levels of prion protein can be used to
distinguish Alzheimer's disease from
creutzfeldt-jakob disease the apoe4
allele is the biggest genetic risk
factor for Alzheimer's disease and I
will talk a little bit more about the
apoe4
protein isoform in the next slide
angiogenic is a secreted rnas that
stimulates angiogenesis but has also
been linked to neurological disease and
ALS in particular although increased
plasma levels of angiogenesis Hymas
disease have also been described FA bb3
is also known as heart fatty acid
binding protein and linked to cardiac
function however several studies have
shown that increased at a BP three
levels in cerebral spinal fluid are
linked to Alzheimer's disease ferritin
is a biomarker of Alzheimer's disease
outcomes and its expression is regulated
by a bowi so that's the the recap of the
analytes in this panel and now I'm going
to get into the apoe4 isoform a little
bit more specifically so the human a
pony protein isoforms differ from each
other at only two amino acids with a
bowi for having arginine zat
112 and 158 whereas a bowi two and a
bowi three isoforms have either one or
two cysteines at these positions the
alleles for each of the three a bowi
isoforms are present in different
frequencies in healthy and Alzheimer's
populations the table below shows the
frequency of the apoE genotypes and the
notable increased presence of the apoe4
allele in individuals with Alzheimer's
apoE has a plethora of functions one of
which appears to be regularly regulating
amyloid beta the apoE
isoforms can differentially affect
clearance of amyloid beta from the brain
thereby influencing aggregation and
plaque formation and human neuroscience
panel two we employ an antibody pair
with high specificity for the apoe4
isoform the graph on the right shows a
dose-dependent
detection of the apoE isoforms with our
apoe4 assay from human neuroscience
panel two so even at very high
concentrations of a PO a two and a boat
III recombinant protein there is still
less than 5% cross reactivity with the
apoe4 bead
you
the assay protocol for human
neuroscience panel 2 follows a similar
format to many of our other kits for
circulating biomarkers after the plate
is pre wet and a preparatory step the
capture bead the capture step is
performed by adding capture beads and
assay buffer to the standards and
samples human neuroscience panel 2 is
validated for CSF plasma and serum at a
1 to 10 dilution of each sample type so
that's the dilution factor that's
recommended and so because of that
dilution factor it's not necessary to
use a serum matrix with this kit for two
of the analytes however angiogenic and
apoe4 we recommend a greater dilution
one to two hundred should be sufficient
if the user is working with plasma and
serum but for all the analytes it's a 1
to 10 dilution in CSF we recommend an
overnight incubation at 4 degrees
however the protocol can be shortened to
a one day protocol performing a two hour
incubation instead we recommend that
once an incubation protocol for the
capture step is determined though that
you stick with it throughout the course
of your study for the sake of
consistency after the capture step is
complete the plate is washed and
incubated with the detection antibody
cocktail for one hour for human
Neuroscience panel to the detection
antibody cocktail contains BIOS and
early detection antibodies against all
of the targets except angio genic the
biotin related detection antibody for
angiogenesis as the standard curve for
this analyte is stunted without Co
incubation of the capture and detection
antibodies after one hour at room
temperature for the detection antibody
cocktail the reporter solution sa PE is
added and the plate is incubated for an
additional thirty minutes at room
temperature
after the SA PE incubation the plate is
washed and the beads are resuspended in
sheath fluid for analysis on Lumina
instrumentation
so now I'll show you some data that we
generated with cerebral spinal fluid
samples from a small cohort of
Alzheimer's disease patients and healthy
controls using cumin neuroscience panel
2 while these studies generally need
larger sample sizes our objective here
was not published novel data but just to
demonstrate an application of multiplex
technology for a pony for on the top
left corner only two of eight samples
from the healthy control group we're
positive for a pony for protein and
that's about the distribution that we'd
expect based upon the prevalence of the
apoe4 allele in the general population
in contrast apoe4 protein was detected
in all of the Alzheimer's disease
samples although we do not see any
significant changes in CSF trem - and
the ada samples we did observe increases
in prion protein as well as neuro
granite
you
here I used human Neuroscience panel 2
to evaluate serum and plasma from AD
patients and healthy controls we
observed some interesting trends such as
an increase in serum CREM 2 and serum fa
beeeep III serum neuro Brannon was often
below the minimum detectable
concentration and healthy controls but
was detectable in the majority of
Alzheimer's disease serum samples we
also evaluated plasma samples although I
should point out that we did not have
matched serum and plasma samples so we
were evaluating different patient
cohorts for trem - although we observed
similar trends with regards to the
sample values and the average
concentrations in both serum and plasma
there was no statistically significant
difference between the normal group and
the Alzheimer's disease group in plasma
however we did see an increase in plasma
values for prion protein in the
Alzheimer's disease group taken together
our analysis of these biomarkers shows
the versatile performance of human
neuroscience panel 2 in various
biological samples
another advantage of multiplex protein
detection is that it is a great for data
mining we took the same CSF sample sets
that we had evaluated with human
neuroscience panel 2 and we also ran
them on human amyloid beta and tau panel
then we analyzed the data looking for
correlations between analytes and the
normal and CSF sample sets with human
neuroscience panel 2 within that kit we
observed a weak correlation between fa
beeeep III and neuro grandin in the
healthy control group but a much
stronger correlation between these
analytes and the Alzheimer's disease
group when we compared the analytes in
human Neuroscience panel 2 with the
established biomarkers in the human
amyloid beta and tau kit we saw that
both neuro Grandon and fa beeeep III
correlated with phospho tau while the
significance of these associations is
unclear the take-home message is that
multiplexing can expose patterns that
may not otherwise be discovered
I would like to transition to talking
about the newest addition to our amino
acid portfolio the SMC X Pro and its
associated kits for single molecule
counting
SMC stands for single molecule counting
and the general assay principle is shown
in the schematic below the SMC
immunoassay it follows the same
rationale as a traditional sandwich
Eliza with an SMC kit you have capture
and detection reagents that form a
sandwich complex the capture antibody is
coated on two magnetic beads while the
detection antibody is labeled with a
fluorophore what distinguishes the SMC
assay is a proprietary Aleutian step
where the sandwich complex dissociates
and the individual fluorescently
labelled detection antibodies are
digitally counted to get an idea of the
typical SMC workflow I've reiterated the
assay steps below and included volumes
and plate types so most of the assay
setup occurs in a 96-well plate the
initial incubation is 200 microlitre
volume 100 microliters of that is the
sample or standard and the other 100
microliters is the capture bead the
plates is then transferred to a magnet
and washed before the addition of 20
microliters of detection antibody and
then incubation to generate the sandwich
complex the plate then goes through a
series of washes to remove excess
detection antibody prior to the aleutian
step after the aleutian the capture
beads can be magnetically separated
allowing the researcher to isolates the
lu8
which contains the label detection
antibody this toilet is transferred to a
384-well plate containing the
neutralization buffer after the
neutralization step the SI is ready to
be analyzed on an SMC
instruments
currently our Millah poor Sigma SMC kits
can be run on two instruments the arena
which is the first generation fluidics
driven system and the new SMC X Pro
which is the second generation platform
the data table highlights the
specifications of each system both
instruments read from a 384 well plate
some of the improvements to the SMC x
pro include a smaller footprint so it's
a true benchtop instrument and a more
rapid runtime which allows researchers
to run an experiments generate and
analyze data all on the same day as well
as a simplified readout the arena had
took the Reina took three measurements
which were tected events event photons
and total photons and that produced
three standard curves and utilizes
weighted algorithm to incorporate the
three measurements and assign sample
values the SMC X Pro just uses a single
readout which is response and that is
generated by a scanning confocal laser
which surveys the sample wells of a 384
well plate digitally counting molecules
of fluorescently labelled detection
antibody
we have recently released an SMC kit for
the amyloid-beta
42 peptide this kit has been validated
in accordance with the benchmarks
described earlier for the measurement of
amyloid beta 42 in cerebrospinal fluid
and a 1 to 20 dilution and in plasma at
a 1 to 4 dilution from the standard
curve on the Left
generated on the SMC X Pro you can see
that the assay sensitivity is not an
issue for this kit as the wounded Swain
diluted normal CSF samples overlaid onto
the standard curve are falling in the
middle of the curve to give you an idea
of the consistency between the SMC
instruments on the right you can see the
excellent correlation of these CSF
samples when their values were compared
between when they were obtained on the
arena and then on the second generation
SMC X Pro and there's again excellent
correlation the bottom figure
demonstrates that the a beta 42 SMC kit
detects the well established decrease of
a beta 42 and the CSF of Alzheimer's
disease patients
you
I would now like to review a few points
to summarize today's webinar I hope that
it has been instructive regarding the
principles and workflow of our Mille
Plex and SMC immunoassays the data I
shared using the human neuroscience
panel - demonstrates a powerful
application of multiplex technology
which is the ability to generate a large
amount of data from a small amount of
sample even though we were working with
small sample cohorts our multiplex
analysis allowed us to observe some
interesting trends including some
correlations between Alzheimer's disease
biomarkers hopefully this illustrates
the utility of integrating this
technology into your neurodegenerative
disease research finally our SMC
technology enables the measurements of
low abundant proteins and biological
samples this sensitivity allows
researchers to accurately measure small
changes in protein concentration and
potentially identify disease before the
onset of symptoms
I would like to thank you all for your
attention
I would also like to acknowledge several
people within the immunoassay platform
solutions rnd group at Miller Park Sigma
including Shao Qiang Josef Wong mumun
Banerjee Lu Chen and Sarah hamrin I
would also like to acknowledge members
of our marketing and product management
team who have worked on these
technologies and helps make this webinar
possible including Tina corn Mayer
Elizabeth Adkison Jones Sudha and Mary
Ann port thanks again
Anthony thank you for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar if you have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appear on the screen and click that send
button we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for so let's get started
and take a look at our audience
questions coming in already
our first question Anthony is if this
kit can distinguish a PO e isoforms my
best technology also be able to
distinguish mutant proteins
excellent question
multiplex protein detection can have
exquisite sensitivity making it feasible
to distinguish isoforms differing by a
single amino acid there are several
instances of mutations associated with
the neurodegenerative disease and for
example trem two mutations are
associated with Alzheimer's so the
ability to measure mutant proteins would
be very pertinent for neurodegenerative
disease researchers and also very
pertinent in the field of cancer
research the limiting factor for being
able to develop an immunoassay specific
for a mutant protein is antibody
availability so if there are antibodies
specific for the mutant protein then
that would open up the possibility of
being able to develop a mutation
specific amino acid
Thank You Anthony and thank you to our
audience members questions coming in our
next question can analytes from separate
kids be combined into a single essay the
short answer is sometimes there are
several factors that can kind of feed
into the answer a sample dilution is a
key factor so analytes that vary
significantly in abundance will often
not have a compatible dilution factor
range where they could fit into the same
immunoassay kit however we do have a
custom assay program and the custom is a
team can assess the feasibility of
combining analytes from separate kits
into a single amino acid a single
customized product so the combination of
analytes is feasible our custom assay
team can expedite the development
process and deliver mates order kit
thank you we have one more question and
I want to remind our audience members
that any question is not answered after
the presentation will be answered via
email our last question is what if I
have a mouse model expressing a human
transgene well your kids detect the
human protein or Mouse or both
so a kit for detecting human proteins
should be able to detect the human trans
gene expressed on the mouse provided
that the sample matrix is similar
however some of our human protein assays
will also be able to detect the
homologous mouse protein and it really
varies depending on the analyte so
although it wasn't mentioned in my
presentation one of the things we look
at during kit validation is an
assessment of cross species reactivity
for each analyte and our technical
support team can access this data and
then answer specific questions about the
cross species reactivity of individual
analytes
thank you so much and Anthony did you
want to provide any closing remarks for
our audience with our time that we have
left together no I just like to think
thank them for their attention and I
guess we'll have the email follow-up
chat for a more extended Q&A wonderful
thank you and I want to thank you again
for your presentation and lab roots and
our sponsor milah por Sigma for today's
presentation I just want to remind our
audience members before we go that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when the webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now
and thanks for joining us today we hope
to see you again soon
bye-bye